[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is "The Diamond Setter,"
published tomorrow in the US.
So this is the first event.
Translated wonderfully
by Jessica Cohen.
I'll start by reading a
paragraph, the prologue.
Well.
"One day in the summer
of 2011, a Syrian citizen
sneaked across the border into
Israel, not far from the town
of [INAUDIBLE].
In his pocket was a
piece of a blue diamond
that had once belonged, so I
was told, to European royalty,
as well as to the Ottoman
Sultan Abdul Hamid II.
After entering Israel, the young
man took a bus to Tel Aviv.
He had not told anyone
in Syria of his plans,
and almost no one in Israel
knew where he'd come from.
Who was this man, and what
was the purpose of his trip?
All we know is that
he was 20 years old,
the scion of two families
divided by national conflict
yet bound by
passion and secrecy,
back in the days when
the Middle East was
steeped not only in
blood, but also in love.
This is his marvelous story
and the story of many others
who live in this land."
Well, this is the beginning.
Now how shall I introduce
a book in which you
find one century, two families,
three cities, and four
generations?
I'll start with a scene
which is not in the book.
That is me standing in northern
Israel a couple of years ago.
There's a famous poetry
festival there every year.
I've been there with my
boyfriend, the poet Dory Manor.
And then I got a
call from my father
saying that my grandmother
had passed away.
And then I was standing there.
I saw Lebanon.
This is the north
side of Israel.
I saw Lebanon, Beirut.
I was looking towards
Damascus, which
is not very far from there.
Hometown of my grandparents.
And I knew, I sadly
knew that I would not
get there maybe any day.
I mean, maybe never.
So this yearning,
this longing for years
for this homeland
of my ancestors
was the seed of this book,
"The Diamond Setter."
Well, as you can
already tell, my family
is from Damascus, the
side of my father.
In fact, my father was the only
one not to be born in Damascus.
He was born in Tel Aviv,
but all his elder sisters
and brother and his parents
were born in Damascus.
And my father, Moshe Sakal--
I am named after him--
he was a teacher.
He taught Arabic and French
at [INAUDIBLE] in Damascus.
And he wrote prose in Arabic.
And ever since he settled
down in Tel Aviv in '49,
he stopped writing.
Now you can say that this is
the tragedy of any immigrant,
right?
Immigrants go to another
country and they lose track
with their former
place, hometown.
But this case is a
little bit different,
because unlike other people
who came from the Holocaust
to Israel from Europe and they
had very difficult stories,
all I was told were beautiful
stories about the life
that they left in Damascus.
And they came to Tel Aviv.
They were pretty much wealthy.
They weren't-- lack anything.
But there was one thing missing,
and that thing was their story.
My father always told me,
you know, we are Sephardic.
We are Syrians.
Of course, it's not a shame.
You should be proud of it.
But I didn't know what it meant.
And he said to me, son,
always know that we
were never discriminated.
Never.
And then one day, I
told him, yes, of course
we were discriminated,
because you were not
allowed to have your own story.
What I mean by
saying that aloud,
I mean that what meant being
Israeli in the '40s, '50s
in 20th century, that
meant not being anything
else, because the
country was very young.
So in order to create its
identity, you were not Polish,
you were not Syrian,
you were not French,
you were not all these things.
That meant that
you were Israeli.
Now as a part of the
third generation,
I can allow myself--
I have the privilege of
going back to these places,
to these stories.
And not by being
sentimental, but to find my--
if you wish, my roots,
to know who I am.
But all this was missing, and
that's why at the age of 22,
I left for Paris, France.
I felt that I needed to be
a stranger, not to be local,
not to belong.
And there I found my diaspora.
Also I found the love of my
life, who is Israeli as well.
And we met in France
in the city of lights.
And then six years after, I
came back to Israel with my--
felt that I had the
diaspora in my suitcase.
Well, back to my family story
and to "The Diamond Setter."
So I'm telling a story
about a place and time
which is not very far from
where we are sitting now.
I mean, not sitting,
but I mean the time.
It's less than a century ago.
I'm talking about
the '30s, the '40s.
And this Middle East
that I'm talking about
had open borders, which is
a thing that is unbelievable
nowadays.
Back in the days where my
grandfather, Moshe Sakal,
was living in Damascus,
he could go and do
shopping from Damascus
in Baghdad, Iraq.
Then he could go and meet a
friend in Anjafa, Palestine.
And then to go to Cairo,
Egypt, and so on and so on.
You could have
friends everywhere.
You can be in love with
people from other countries.
You could just walk freely.
And I understood while
trying to write this book,
because in the beginning, I
only had the Jewish-Israeli side
of the book.
But I was sure that
this was not it.
Something was missing,
and what was missing
was this open borders situation.
And as a writer, you know,
[INAUDIBLE] you can write about
everything, but you don't.
Because you have-- you need
to have the courage to do so.
And I had to open these borders.
I didn't know how.
And then one day I read in
the newspaper about a teacher,
30 years old from Damascus,
who just crossed the border.
He went from Damascus to
Tel Aviv and then to Jaffa
to see the house of
his grandparents.
And I was shocked
by his courage.
He did an incredible thing.
It was not as a part of a
movement, a political movement.
No.
He just went by his
own decision to see
the house of his
grandfather and grandmother
who had left Jaffa in
'48 before the war,
and then afterwards
were not allowed
to go back to their home,
and they stayed in Damascus.
And that gave me first the
idea and then the courage
to write about this.
And my character
is named Fareed.
He's inspired by this act
of this Syrian teacher.
He's 20 years old.
And one day, just
as I read, in 2011
he crosses this
well-protected border,
and he goes first to Tel
Aviv and then to Jaffa.
Bride of the sea, as this
town is called in Arabic,
to see the house of
his grandparents.
And before he does that, he has
a friend, a pen pal in Jaffa,
which he finds on Facebook.
And he says to him, I'm going
to Jaffa to explore my roots.
And his friend in Jaffa
says, "'Are you crazy?
They'll shoot you at the border.
They have no qualms.
You think they don't have
enough Palestinians in Israel?
They don't want another one.
And anyway, nothing
scares the Israeli army
more than an unarmed Arab.
If you went at them
with a submachine gun,
that would be one thing.
But to just walk
over and with the way
you look, with your curly hair
and your pale skin, no way.
Forget it.
Very bad idea.
You won't make it here alive.'"
Of course, Fareed doesn't
listen, and he goes to Jaffa.
And with one little
step of his, he just
opened literally the border,
as if it doesn't exist.
Well, that was one way
of opening these borders,
these boundaries.
The second one was by digiti--
the second one was by
digitization and by Grindr.
I wouldn't say Tinder, because
my characters use Grindr.
And you know, I talk
about these borders.
If you go to Northern Israel
and you look at Beirut,
you can't go there.
But you can go on Grindr.
And then you can find someone
you like, and you can tell him,
you know, if there was no border
here, I would be in your arms
in, like, 15
minutes, 10 minutes.
Well, it's not always possible,
but in my book, it is.
I won't tell you how.
But I will read a paragraph
about my character, Honi,
in Tel Aviv.
"For months now,
Honi's gaze had been
fixed not on trees or people
or sidewalks or the road,
but on his phone,
which offered up
an entire world,
countless opportunities,
unrealized desires,
disappointments foretold,
and dreams that would never
come true unless he suddenly
discovered an extraordinary
reserve of courage
within himself.
He did not believe for a
second that could happen.
He was location-based.
Everywhere he went,
someone out there
knew he was here and not there.
That someone was not God
or an invisible entity,
that someone like
a voice from ahigh,
making anonymous pronouncements,
was merely an algorithm
programmed to do one thing.
To know.
The algorithm knew
everything about Honi,
or at least the most
important thing.
The precise point in
space where he was
located at any given moment.
It was always
hovering above him,
and could always testify when
needed that he was here and not
somewhere else.
The algorithm was his alibi
for a little sin he had not yet
committed, but it was
also the guarantee
that this little sin
would one day come to be.
When?
Maybe today.
Maybe next week.
Maybe never."
Well, once you open the
borders, very interesting things
can happen.
That's when I started
fantasizing or recreating,
one may say, the love
life of my grandparents.
As you can maybe already
tell, my fiction involves--
as you can already tell,
my fiction has a very--
a strong element of truth in it.
Maybe more than in ordinary
novels and fiction.
A few years ago,
I was interviewed
in the most popular
newspaper in Israel.
And I had, like, four
pages of coming out
in this most popular newspaper.
And I didn't dare telling
about this to my grandmother.
Nevertheless, she found it.
Because I wasn't afraid.
I knew that she wasn't reading
any newspapers in Hebrew,
even though she was living for
60 years in Israel by then.
Anyways, she found it.
And she didn't say anything.
But the next time I was at
her place, all of the sudden,
she said, you know,
I read the article.
And I said, you did?
And she said-- she was very
severe, and she said, yes.
Did you really say everything
that was in the paper?
And I said to her, well, yes.
And then she said,
bravo, my son.
You did very well, because I
believe that everything in life
should be told.
You should have no secrets.
Well, it was then that I
permitted, allowed myself
to recreate my
grandparents' love life.
And then one day, I came to the
editor of "The Diamond Setter."
And I told him,
you know, I'm going
to have a love triangle
between Rafael and Adela,
the Jewish couple from
Damascus, and Layla,
the younger, beautiful,
Palestinian woman from Jaffa.
And then he looked at
me and he said, yeah,
you mean love triangle
like they are both in love
with her or someone--
two characters are in
love with the same person?
I said, no.
I mean a real love triangle.
And he said, like a real one?
Like-- and I said, yes.
And then he loved the idea.
The first, he was scared.
He loved it.
And unlike what
people may think,
I find the love
triangle a very severe
and strict model
or a convention,
and not at all free.
Because just imagine
like-- just imagine,
like any other triangle,
once you move one part of it,
all the other angles,
like the two other angles,
they also change.
Like, this is very strict.
Not free at all.
And this gives a place to
incredible and very interesting
things that can
happen, I believe.
And I'll read a short
paragraph about Adela
and Rafael's love
triangle with Layla.
And no spoilers, but I will
say that she's related closely
to our Fareed.
I told you this was a family
saga with lots of secrets.
Well, Adela.
"She did not dare discuss
Layla with Rafael.
She loved him now even
more than before."
I read again.
"She did not dare discuss
Layla with Rafael.
She loved him now
even more than before,
and felt she had enough
love inside herself
for both Rafael and Layla.
Neither of them was deprived.
And in fact, quite the opposite.
The more she loved, the
greater her capacity
to contain the love.
And she filled up
with love as one can
become filled with memories."
So this book is about
yearning, it's about regret,
it's about longing,
it's about return.
And the big question in
this book is, can we return?
Do we have a place to return to?
Of course, I also speak
about the Palestinians' right
of return, which is
the biggest Israel--
biggest taboo in Israel
nowadays and before even.
So I speak about that return.
And we know that
Fareed is going to see
the house of his
beloved grandparents
in Jaffa, in Israel.
But also of other returns.
So I'll read a short dialogue
between the narrator, Tom,
and his boyfriend Honi.
They both are going to fall
in love with our Fareed.
So they speak about this
return, and Tom says,
the narrator says, "'I'm
not only talking about
the political issue with the
Palestinian refugees and all
that.
I mean return in
a broader sense,
in every sense.'" And then Honi
says, "'I'm not following you,
Tommy.
What's the question?'"
And then Tom says, "'The
question is, can you go back?
The question is, can
you really go back?
What really interests me
is not the return itself,
but the place.
You know.
People always fantasize
about a time machine
that can transport you back
to a different time and place.
But my question is, do we even
have anywhere to go back to?
Look, I started writing "The
Diamond Setter--'" he's writing
this own book, my narrator--
"'and I got stuck.
One day, I read in the paper
about that Syrian guy who
crossed the border and went
on a roots journey in Jaffa.
And that little act of his
made all these other things
come together for me.
I realized that for us, the
third generation of immigrants,
we can't do anything to change
the political situation.
Our hands are tied.
But we can tell a story,
and that's a lot.'"
So I write about return.
I may say in the book that
we cannot really go back,
but we can tell a
story by trying to.
And I will finish
this introduction
by reading a short paragraph,
what was told by Aunt Gracia
to the jeweler, the diamond
setter in person when
he's a child.
He's called Menashe.
And I think that this summarizes
quite well all that I was just
talking about.
So this is what this aunt
of his, born in Damascus,
who had met the Turkish
sultan Abdul Hamid,
and who got this blue
diamond from him,
from the Turkish
sultan, she says that
to her beloved nephew in
Tel Aviv when he's a child.
She says, "'I always tell
you everything that happened,
Menashe, because you
are a very sweet boy.
And it's thanks to
you that I remember
things that happened long
ago, in another world,
in another life.
Do you think we can hold onto
everything that happens to us?
You grow up and discover
that your body changes,
and you change on
the inside too.
And all the things
that happen to you,
there is no proof that
they really did happen.
Every memory does
not always last.
You turn your face up to
the sky, inhale and exhale,
you close your eyes, and some
little things come back to you
for a quick second.
But do not believe that
moment will truly return.
Everything you do in life
happens for the first time
and for the last time.
There is nothing afterward, and
there won't be anything left.
But if you understand that, you
will be able to genuinely enjoy
the things you do.
You will be able to hold onto
them as tightly as possible
before they escape you forever.
Do you understand, Menashe?'"
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So there's a famous
quote by an English poet, Percy
Bysshe Shelley.
Not sure if you're
familiar with him.
But he has a quote to
the effect that poets
are the unacknowledged
legislators of the world.
So I know you said that
there's nothing you can do
or that we can do regarding
the political situation,
but you can tell the story.
So my question for you
is, when you set out
to write this story, I
know you sort of described
that moment where it sort came
to you, I guess, so to speak.
Did the sort of
political element
or that situation, did
that factor in-- like,
was that in your head when you
were sort of devising the story
or coming up with it?
Or do you think
that was, I guess,
like the political element just
shaped the story to begin with,
I guess?
Or like, I guess another
way of putting it would be,
did you sort of design
the story with some sort
of political message in mind?
Or was it just the story, and I
guess that's something that, I
guess, was ancillary to it?
MOSHE SAKAL: That's a good
question, and a tough one.
[LAUGH]
Because you know,
writing about politics,
I think it was the Stendhal,
the French writer, who
said that putting
politics into a novel
is like a shotgun in an opera.
Like, this is the
worst thing to do.
Nevertheless, I did it.
And it took me six
years, writing this book.
Six long years.
Lots of crisis.
And I didn't quite
know in the beginning
how to refer to the
political situation.
But of course, obviously,
I knew that I would,
because this is the story.
The story is about people
from different countries
that come to each
other, that connect,
that they feel passion
for one another.
And sometimes I let my narrator
deal with things that maybe I
as a person wouldn't.
And he lets himself say
things and acting the way
he does, and all the
other characters.
I was trying to give all
the angles of the story.
And one thing is sure.
I did not have a message.
Not because I'm not political.
I am very political.
I write for Haaretz
daily newspaper,
for example, about the
political situation when
I have things to say.
But as a writer,
I think that it's
terrible to have a message.
I think that literature
can and does change people,
but differently
than in an article.
In a more profound way.
And I think that
if a book is good,
people are becoming better.
But it's not ignoring
your question.
I think-- as a person,
I am very political.
But in this book, I
just told a story.
And of course, I'm
not being naive
and saying, just told a story.
Because you know, when I
started doing the research,
I found very little books--
I mean, I found very few
books about, for example,
the Palestinian
refugees in Hebrew,
about Jews from
Damascus even in Hebrew.
Most books you find are about--
they deal with the
Shoah, the Holocaust,
with European cultures,
Jewish cultures.
And now it's becoming
more and more familiar.
And people from my generation
and from other generations,
they find these stories.
I came to my grandmother
a few years ago
when she was still alive.
Her Hebrew name
is [? Oa, ?] which
is, it's coming from light.
And her Arabic name
was [? Sopia. ?]
And I asked her
about these stories
and about these places
that she came from,
Damascus and then Beirut.
And then she was flattered,
but she was not at all content,
and she was even
slightly furious at me.
And she said,
[SPEAKING ARABIC]---- in Arabic,
that means my son--
[SPEAKING HEBREW],, in Hebrew,
which means, what for?
Why going back to these stories?
And I told her that for
me, it was very important,
and that I was ashamed of
not knowing these stories,
not knowing where
my family came from.
So I guess that if there was
one political main thing,
main purpose, and main goal in
this book for me, it was this.
Telling the stories, writing
about these people coming
from Palestine, from
Israel, from Syria.
Knowing that they had normal
life, that they loved,
that they felt passion, that
they were yearning, just
like us.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed
on the inside of the book
that it was originally published
in Hebrew four years ago.
And I was curious about
the translation process,
if you could talk about
that a little bit.
Like, how deeply
were you involved?
How did it feel if you
were involved to come back
to the story you'd written many
years prior during translation.
And being an English speaker
yourself, like, was there
anything you felt like was lost
in the translation of the book?
MOSHE SAKAL: Yeah.
OK, thank you.
I'll say a strange
thing, but it came true.
From the beginning, I thought
that this book would interest
the American public readers.
I don't know why.
This is not my first book.
But I knew that this
would be the first one
to be translated into English.
And then I met Jessica Cohen.
She's a great translator.
She has just won with David
Grossman the year's Man Booker.
But that was five years
ago when I met her.
And she read the manuscript
even before it was published
in Hebrew, and she loved it.
And then we started
working on this book.
Now the fact that I am an
English speaker, by the way,
like every Israeli--
it is not very rare in Israel.
So I knew that for
her, it could be--
how you say, a pain in the neck.
I would say this
very delicately.
Because you know, I guess
the translators are always
afraid of writers
coming to them, saying,
why did you choose
this and not that?
And we had dilemmas.
We never fought.
It was very fruitful.
I felt in very good hands.
We surely had some discussions.
Interesting,
complex discussions.
For example, the name, the
right of return in Hebrew,
you have one word for return
of Jews, which is Shiva,
and one word for Palestinians,
which is [? Shavut. ?]
Or the name of
the City of Jaffa.
In Arabic, you call it Yafa.
In Hebrew, you call it Yafo.
So I put in the book, when
a Jewish person says names
the city, he says
the Hebrew word,
and the Palestinian
says the Arabic word.
And what should we do?
And a lot of very
interesting discussions
that involved both mentality
and culture and language.
But in the end, I
said to her always
that her word would
be the final word.
And when she finished the
translation and I read it,
I told her that if I would have
written this book in English,
that is exactly the way that
I would have been writing it.
And then [INAUDIBLE] writing it.
And she said that this
was the biggest compliment
that a translator can have.
So I'm very happy and excited
about this translation
and edition in the
States of the book.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I know you said
that you spent almost-- was it
five years?
MOSHE SAKAL: Six.
AUDIENCE: Six
years on this book.
Is that-- like, I you've
written five novels now.
Is that pretty normal
across the board?
Or was there something
special about this one
that really drew you in?
MOSHE SAKAL: It was
the most difficult one.
Afterwards, I wanted to retire.
[LAUGHTER]
But I started young.
I wrote short stories when I
was 16 years old, because I
knew a guy who
was older than me,
and he gave me very good
books, and I wanted to give him
something in return.
And I didn't read anything.
I mean, adult books
when I was 16 yet.
So I just wrote a short
story, and I gave it to him.
And he was very
enthusiastic about it.
And he said that I
should write more.
And then the first
book of short stories
was published when
I was very young,
when I was 21, in a
well-established publishing
house in Tel Aviv.
And then I wrote several novels
in Paris and in Tel Aviv,
and that was the
most difficult one.
I wrote more than 1,000 pages.
And with my editor,
author [INAUDIBLE],,
he writes crime books.
I mean, [INAUDIBLE].
How would you say--
yeah.
Crime books.
And he's very
elegant as an editor.
And I said to him, OK, listen.
We have 1,000 pages here.
We have to turn them
into 200 in Hebrew.
And that's the book in Hebrew.
So I told him, how do we do it?
And then we decided about
making chapters and, like,
having chapters,
and each chapter
would have a name
of one character.
Because you think, how
would you tell a story
about a century in,
like, 200 pages?
That was too difficult.
And we had to move.
Like, change the apartment.
And I told my
boyfriend, I can't move.
I can't do anything now in my
life until I finish this book.
I had this feeling
that he would--
like, I should finish this
book or it would finish me,
like we say in Hebrew.
Like, it would kill me.
But in the end, it was done
and published a few years ago.
And then I retired
for six months
before I wrote a book
within six months that
was published two years ago.
So that was like a
smooth creation process,
and I felt like I
really deserved it.
DAVID: Thank you Mr. Sakal.
MOSHE SAKAL: Thank you, David.
DAVID: Thank you,
everyone, for coming.
Let's give one more
round of applause.
MOSHE SAKAL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]